the populism question is Central to
understanding kind of libertarianism
right now in 2023 we had this
conversation uh we went into this topic
with Dave Smith on the first episode of
the show um and I want to just play a
little bit of Dave's argu he's very much
in the propop pois camp and this is a
debate that stretches back to kind of
the beginnings of modern American
libertarianism
uh let's have I want to have Dave
articulate his case for libertarian
populism and then kind of delve a little
more deeply into this so let's roll that
best I'm a big believer in the
rothbardian kind of like populist idea
that and look I think you see this with
uh Javier Malay right like this is the
way it can be done like this is the way
to do it is to tap into the this this
kind of populist streak particularly at
a time when the elites have so
mismanaged everything and kind of like
talk to people about how they're being
ripped off like how they're being ripped
off and these guys are doing it to you
and then the the problem with populism
always is that it's completely devout of
any type of theory trumpian movement in
general there's just no it's it's always
like he's railing against everything
that is pretty horrible and then he it's
like so what's your thing and it's like
good deals make the best deals only me
only I can it's like there's nothing
really there but Libertarians already
have that it's like Libertarians have
all the theory but we're missing all of
the like populism to make it like appeal
to to people what do you think of that
uh that argument that um you know it at
the end of the day there are uh there
there is a sort of you know
managerial Elite or at
least people who have that ambition to
uh plan our society and that
Libertarians should be defining
themselves in opposition to that agenda
I think a lot of things about that um
one is that I should always preface that
uh my job uh or my self-conception um uh
is not about the wielding of political
the attainment or the wielding of
political power uh and so when I uh am
asked about you know how should we
attain and wield political power I don't
have great answers or at least you
should take them with all the grain of
salt my job is to do journalism
libertarian journalism um a lot of that
can be very righteous and angry and
frothing and pointing out the just
Brutal mismanagement by the elite
political class it's a huge percentage
of what we do at reason uh and what I've
done in my life before and uh I ever
worked for a reason or really knew much
about the place um so it's part of it
yeah but uh also journalism is just a
different thing it's it's a it's
Gathering of facts I would point to if
we're going to be talking about Marie
rothbard strategy as being something
that that is helpful um you should point
out that um it wasn't always helpful the
Marie rothbard went to some bad places
in the early 199s um uh that is what
happens when you go towards the
attainment of political party and also
power and also like this sort of attempt
and there's something Elite about the
this attempt as well or at least not
Elite it's it's like uh it's a it's a
Temptation that intellectuals and people
who work in the knowledge class um
always are tempted by which is that if I
can just harness this populist feeling
out there I'm going to produce my
intellectual ideological outcome um yeah
you see this with with Marie rothbard
and Lou Rockwell in the early 1990s with
the Roth Rockwell rothbard report uh
they were talking about Joe Senator Joe
McCarthy tail Gunner Joe as being a role
model they were saying nice things about
David Duke um they cozied up to Pat
Buchanan um at the time as a kind of
predictive element of where a segment of
the population was going to go as as a
sort of John the Baptist figures uh for
Donald Trump they were on to something
absolutely and they were on to something
much more than I certainly expected so
hats off for you know sort of like the
describing a a world as it exists rather
the world than I thought it was um but
as a a place where a person can go um
and uh and like and hold on to one's
libertarianism or one's ideology it was
corrupting those types of things are
corrupting U it's going to lead you to
positions like Lou Rockwell had of like
defending the cops against Rodney King
of a writing just really horrible things
like the the early 1990s stuff that came
uh whether it's in the Ron Paul
newsletters or the or the rothbard
Rockwell report and all these kind of
things it's it's very noxious it's very
anti-libertarian
um it went to a bad place uh and you
could say that admiring Ro uh rothbart
for plenty of other things that he
contributed in his life but he was
always kind of a political schemer um
one way to look at this and take
rothbard and take libertarian politics
out of this for a second is um look at
the difference between what what Chris
rufo does and what uh for instance the
found for individual rights and
education does they are always at
loggerheads even though they frequently
have the same kind of uh opponents in
the world it's just a different approach
fire um uses a they're sort of Tethered
to a set of principles which they apply
hopefully uh and in my view uh usually
um very consistently uh across time rufo
is is going towards power um political
power like Ronda santis in Florida and
trying to influence it I think both
approaches are valid by the way and I
think like absolutely Chris ruo has
influenced uh American policy and debate
more than a lot of private actors have
for a long time um but I think it's also
corrupting you're going to lead to bad
laws which I think some of that has
happened in Florida so um it's
libertarian Pop I think libertarian is
naturally populist in that sense it is a
a position from which you critique the
application of power and you correctly
identify that especially those people
who say that oh we're just over here
like trying to solve problems that that
is actually ideological even uh as much
or more ideologically or more
influentially ideological than
libertarianism is and yeah Javier Malay
going a a bunch and ripping stuff off of
wall is awesome I would love to see that
as I would love to see someone uh
articulate in the way that he has in
those videos that we've all seen talking
about economics and just rapid fire
insane you know Nick gpie on on crank uh
kind of mode that's that's all thrilling
and exciting but let's also remember um
the conditions that brought him were so
horrible and I hope we don't live to see
them in this country would yeah and
there's a it's it's also it's also uh
you know targeted at a the from a
Libertarian perspective it's grounded we
talked about this with Dave too it's
grounded in libertarian Theory and he is
when he's you know saying AA and ripping
things off he's talking about
dismantling unnecessary government
bureaucracies which all of us in this
conversation agree with and like when I
think about populism um I I I agree
largely with it you're saying Matt that
there's a sort of cynicism to
Libertarians embracing it uh because
populism can almost be its own uh
ideology it's like it is the belief that
there is just that Elites um themselves
are kind of inherently bad and I I think
for Libertarians it's like well no it's
more like people who are using their
Elite status to infringe on others
Liberties are bad like in in a free
Society there you know we would have you
know academics and we would have uh you
know Titans of industry and so like so
there there would be kind of like
natural Elite so we're we're not against
that necessarily but uh we're against
Natural Elites Zack Weiss Miller well
we're we're against like uh you know the
K CLA Schwabs of the world uh who is
himself
defining uh himself against libertarian
he he said you know Libertarians these
anti-stem people are the enemy um and so
you know I I have no problem being kind
of like creeped out by like the the
dastardly plans of the world economic
Forum even though I don't think that you
know they're they're out there you know
eating babies uh that but they they want
to they they they have a vision they
have the a kind of you know technocratic
vision of the world they have this this
idea that um you know we're we're gonna
kind of meld uh public and private and
we're we're you know have we're gonna
have stakeholder capitalism we're gonna
kind of go the China model that that is
something to be alarmed about and
worried about and and to the degree that
you know resisting that is quotequote
populism fine but this kind of unored
populism and and appealing to just like
a an a vague sense of uh the elites are
are controlling everything I think that
is where we start to run into big
problems well wouldn't libertarian
populists counter to both of you because
I I do want to sort of play devil's
advocate for a second here I think I
agree with what you guys are saying but
wouldn't the libertarian populist if one
were in the room with us
counter Zach they shut you inside your
house in Los Angeles for you know a a
really long time to the point where you
felt the need to move your entire family
to Florida to ensure your kids didn't
grow up masked Matt you know same for
you in New York City I mean you have
basically been betrayed by the state
that has locked you inside your houses
for many months on end and basically
removed Public Schools as an option
available to your children what has the
state done for you and Liz and Liz they
blocked you from going to church right
yeah I mean legitimately block people
from going to church that is such a
radicalizing notion I mean just cut off
they did all of this to us and then they
basically said you know Matt and Liz in
order to possibly enter a New York City
restaurant uh with your family you have
to show proof that you've gotten the
vaccine a bunch of times at a certain
point right because they required
multiple doses oh and then by the way
Zach those questions you had about the
origins of this whole virus and whether
or not there was a lab leak well
actually we're going to censor and
suppress a whole bunch of information
journalistic information that attempts
to get to the bottom of this even though
it's all happened in China you know
where the CCP sorry I did my best Donald
Trump ask China but like we're the CCP
we know it's not generally transparent
with us right like so when you when you
tally up what they've done to us over
the last four or so years not to mention
every single year they take Hefty Hefty
of our paychecks how could you not hate
the state like at a
certain well it's not yeah it's it's not
about that and let let me just give one
counter to that and I I'm curious to
hear Matt weigh in on this but you know
when you talk about they locked me down
in Los Angeles it was basically one
person named Barbara ferer who was the
public health authority for LA County
who's like a uh you know a master's of
Public Health or something like that and
then who was it that ultimately declared
that uh you know locking people out of
their churches was unconstitutional it
was a bunch of robed Elites from ivy
league from the ivy league uh sitting on
the Supreme Court so it's not as simple
as like the elites versus the non-
elites are are on your side or or not on
your side and and that's I guess my
point is like we should be looking more
at what is what are the mechanisms for
these infr
rather than like what kind of strata of
society or culture is it coming from but
I do think it is worth pointing out that
like Barbara Farrar and you know Big
City Mayors um whether Garcetti or
DeBlasio were all taking their cues from
Anthony fouchy and then the teachers
unions and Randy wi Garten Who Matt has
written about extensively right like to
some degree there was a level of uh
coordination maybe not in the sort of
sense that people Envision of like well
the Deep state is conspiring against us
but there is certainly uh well the CDC
says one thing and Anthony fouchy says
one thing and then all of these big City
Mayors take their cues from that and so
on and so forth Matt what do you make of
all this that um is I mean I've always
used the phrase political class in thata
in in many cases and this is absolutely
true and it was an actual conspiracy in
that people met together and made
decisions I mean the the classic case is
the February
2021 new Biden Administration guidelines
at the CDC about distancing in in public
schools uh where the new uh CDC director
relle wilinsky made a recommendation
that was counter to her own personal
recommendation of the summer previously
when she was a private citizen uh
because um she had Randy wearden
president of the American Federation of
teachers in on those scientific
discussions and since a huge swath of
the country the one run by democrats for
the most part basically followed CDC
dictat on uh these things that meant
that sentenced kids to further time in
halftime or remote schooling and there
was a Revolt uh that happened in
Massachusetts and elsewhere and they had
to scramble and revise those
calculations a month later um but it
showed that that thing was was corrupted
from from root and branch and yes the
the elites and this and I would include
here the journalistic class too as part
of the political class right now you
have a large swath of Journalism dumb
who are cheering on censorship by the
Biden Administration like we have to
combat Co misinformation and if that
means you know taking Joe Rogan off
Spotify well darn it that's just what
we've got to do it's insane um and we
should have contempt towards that um I
would just say in my own little hippie
Corner over here we just had Martin
Luther King day here and I'm always glad
to see people look up his various
writings and speeching about everything
and and I've always been I think the
perhaps greatest or certainly you know
top five pieces of American uh political
writing and rhetoric is letter from
Birmingham Jail which has the four steps
essential steps in his position or his
his point of view uh uh towards uh
creating a nonviolent campaign of uh of
nonv vience um resistance and uh two of
those steps are always uh kind of
overlooked uh but one of them is the uh
Gathering of facts right not fictions
but facts uh the other one is
self-purification um which is to say um
if your heart is filled with hate you're
going to do bad at at at doing
persuasive convincing protest so um I
have contempt for a lot of the actions
that you described Liz and even you
bringing them up again makes the blood
pressure kind of go up and and get all
prickly um I try not to be governed by
hate I don't think uh encouraging people
to hate the state is going to lead to
Great outcomes but that's just me
personally um and again I'm not in the
power wielding business um I know that
if I'm governed by hate uh of you know
the protesters blocking the Williamsburg
Bridge when I want to cross it um that
I'm probably GNA get to some bad policy
ideas so I try to not do it hey thanks
for watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to recent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcast